Let's go next to our caller from the five
41 area code.
Who's calling today from five four one.
Hi David.
This is Jordan from Eugene, Oregon.
Hey Jordan.
What's up?
Hi.
I'm, I tweeted you about this the other day,
but I thought I'd call you for the first time.
Um, and I had a thought, um, when it comes
to the impeachment, and right now Nancy Polosi
is holding, uh, the articles are going to
the Senate if we're going to trial.
So it's kinda this weird stalemate.
Is it possible that we can go into the next
presidential election assuming that Trump
loses office and someone else gets in, that
they can actually have a trial after there
is a new president on Trump?
You know, I don't know the answer to that
to be perfectly Frank.
So, so the idea would be Nancy Pelosi holds
articles of impeachment.
The president has been impeached, uh, then
Trump loses and then you have a different
president in, but you still do an impeachment
trial of Trump.
I think that you prop, my instinct is you
can't, because impeachment is an impeachment
trial is ultimately a vote about whether to
remove the president.
If the president's already gone, it makes
it moot.
And maybe it could still have some symbolic
meaning, but I don't think so.
I think you've got to do, I think you've got
to do the impeachment trial while the president
is still president.
That's, I mean, that makes a lot of sense.
The only thing I was thinking about was like,
cause technically since no one has ever been
convicted in my mind, uh, from a trial, uh,
that so there's never really been a consequence
other than removing a president cause there
potentially could be additional consequences
rather than just other than just being removed.
That's why I was thinking that way.
Well there can be, once the president is no
longer president, they can conceivably could
be indicted for crimes.
But, um, it's, it's, uh, I, I think our priority
should be let's remove him in November no
matter what.
And at a certain point, let's, let's do the
trial in the Senate probably before the election.
I think it has to be, but maybe Nancy Pelosi
knows better than I do.
Yeah, it's a good possibility.
But, um, I enjoyed hearing your thoughts,
David.
Thank you very much.
All right, thank you.
Appreciate the call.
Thanks very much.